a coronary angiography or cardiac
catheterization is an x-ray examination
of the vessels and chambers of the heart
often done to identify any narrowed or
clogged coronary arteries that are
preventing blood from reaching the heart
muscle the study can also be used to
measure the size and function of the
chambers of the heart and the function
of the heart valves when you arrive at
the hospital an intravenous line will be
started you will be placed on a heart
monitor and you may be given an oral or
intravenous sedative to help you relax
most coronary angiography procedures
lasts between one and two hours before
the procedure you will be placed on a
table equipped with the fluoroscope an
x-ray imaging device during the
procedure the fluoroscope will move
around your chest in all directions to
record pictures of your heart and
coronary arteries from multiple angles
most cardiac catheterizations take place
through the femoral artery in the groin
but can also be done through an artery
in the arm the doctor numbs the skin in
your groin area and inserts a needle
into your femoral artery once the needle
is placed a wire is passed to the needle
and gently guided through the arterial
system to the heart the needle will be
withdrawn and exchanged for a small
flexible tube called a sheath the
permits access to your femoral artery
next a soft flexible catheter will be
slipped over the wire through the sheath
and threaded up to your heart your
physician will watch the movement of the
catheter on the fluoroscope you may feel
pressure as the wire and sheath are
inserted but you will not feel their
movement inside your arteries to
evaluate the coronary arteries your
doctor will remove the guide wire
position the tip of the catheter just
inside the arteries one at a time and
inject a special dye this dye allows the
fluoroscope to take x-ray images cut
angiograms
of the arteries interior any blockages
will be clearly identified as the
arteries fill with dye you may feel
flushed or slightly nauseated when the
dye is injected after sufficient images
of both coronary arteries and their
tributaries have been recorded the
catheter will be removed through the
groin pressure must be applied
over the femoral artery to prevent
bleeding you will then be taken to the
recovery room for 30 to 60 minutes of
observation after which you will be
required to lie on your back for several
hours with a pressure bandage in place
over your groin you may either be
discharged home on the same day or after
an overnight stay in the hospital